step one is obsessed get totally focused
unleash your desire that gives the
energy step two is not waiting its
massive action keep change your approach
until you find effective execution if
you're running east looking for a sunset
I don't care how positive you are you're
not going to be the thing that is the
wrong strategy it's just not going to
happen so you got to have a proven
strategy and you can get there faster
same way I've done it with these books
is saying I could go this or I could
spend four years interview 50 of the
smartest people in the world all
billionaires are starting with nothing
about it what they did and take
compressed decades in two days that's
really the purpose of everything that I
do so when you have that plan and keep
changing your approach I always tell
people you know how long would you give
the average kid to learn how to walk
before you turn the kid and said it's
never going to happen you're not a
walker just give it up
thank you are you crazy I keep going to
keep trying until well that's really
step two you keep changing your approach
simply fine and then the third step to
achieve it really is simple that they
sound if you're obsessed you know what
you want you take a massive action maybe
you modeled somebody figure out the
right action so you get there quicker
and you're executing you still need a
little grace some people call it luck
you could call it God but I really
believe that there's the part we do and
then there's the part that comes to us
but I do know grace shows up a lot more
when you do the first two steps on your
own and grace shows up a lot more when
you acknowledge grace in your life when
you acknowledge that I was born in a
world what I didn't have to build this
internet that I can pull out of my
pocket answer anything on earth I'm
driving on streets
I didn't pay I'm reading books I didn't
have to write that's the gift of our
lives and I think when we experience
that grace we don't just experienced
more achievement but we start to
experience more fulfilling and grace not
only affects your ability to get there
but it affects what you do and how you
lean you live once you are there it
really determines the quality of your
life because unless you live in a state
of gratitude you know I did an interview
with Sir John Templeton and as you know
is one of the first billionaire
investors and just a brilliant man he
came from nothing and he don't eat I
think with seven or fifteen they still
do it the Templeton fund I think it's
seven and fifty million dollars a year
it's bigger than a Nobel funds that he
donates
and one day I asked them I said what is
the secret to wealth he looked to me
pause this big smile as I got really
bright like they always did and he said
Tony it's what you teach
I said why he's a lot of things you know
it's thing he said gratitude he said
because you night only no billionaires
that are miserable and it's because
they're not grateful for what they have
and we both know people have no money
seemingly but they're so grateful for
their health for their husbands their
life for their children they're so
grateful and godness will people for
their life that they're rich you know so
I think I think it starts with that
gratitude it starts with that connection
to grace is simplistic as that sounds
and so it's not enough just have your
financial plan you have all the money
and be miserable
whatever money and be really rich
emotionally psychologically fredley